Ryan it's good to see you again Daniel
it's nice to meet you for the first time
so first of all who would you love to
have casted in Knives Out Three I'm
thinking ahead okay yeah who do you
think yeah give us give us some ideas I
would like to see Angelina Jolie oh my
God are you kidding oh that would be
that would be amazing that would be
phenomenal
together for us yeah do you know make
the call I mean I could try a little
something I could try a little something
um I'm gonna try and get Daniel Craig in
the next one if I can pull that off then
yeah I feel like I feel like today's
price was probably not yesterday's price
so
hey what are you talking about yeah
[Laughter]
uh Daniel who would you say is a cast
member that you think would make a great
detective in real life
well we used to play Mafia on a Saturday
night which is a bit beyond me but like
why a game getting away with a perfectly
good drink but anyway
um
Hudson was very serious
um Janelle Monae was very serious about
it
um Janelle would dress up in character I
don't know where she got these from but
I think she just carries a whole
wardrobe with it and she came as
Sherlock Holmes and just was like you
know so
um I think those two would be pretty
good a pretty good team yeah yeah
who would you not
yes that's in the cast if you could pick
one because I wouldn't trust any of them
I love this game
um who would you say is the best at a
game of Clue in the cast
well again Leslie and Kate take the
rules of Mafia so seriously
uh Leslie and also Leslie's a chess guy
Leslie yeah I'm playing chess so I
wouldn't yeah I wouldn't like to go up
against Leslie yeah yeah
I loved seeing you and Dave together
what was that like well we see it again
it seems to be happening doesn't it so I
mean
just to give me a part in dude Maybe
I love it and lastly I didn't know you
could dance like that that the viral
vodka video you can dance like that so
you can dance
yeah I'm like maybe there's dancing in
this Like Dancing with the Stars for you
in the future like are you yeah right
yeah is that oh yeah I can't wait doing
the musical for the next one yeah it
could happen yeah you heard it here
first yeah so there's no possibility
ever in life no dancing anywhere else
was that the end no what did they say
dance you like there's someone looking
so you know mainly mainly no one's
looking